es momento de pasar a nuestra revista de
prensa que el día de hoy abrimos
haciendo un breve repaso por las
portadas de los principales medios
franceses de que de manera unánime
reflejan Este martes la nueva jornada de
movilizaciones contra la reforma de
Manuel macron y para entrar en materia
está conmigo Marta Moya Marta Buen día
para usted y bueno cuéntenos Cómo abren
las noticias Buenos días Ángela como
decíamos sexta jornada de movilizaciones
en Francia de estos sindicatos y dos de
cada tres franceses que rechazan la
reforma pensional de Manuel macron de
los 62 a los 64 años por tanto la prensa
francesa hoy unánime en sus portadas de
la prensa escrita al respecto de esta
materia hemos destacado cinco portadas
la primera es la de liberación que dice
el primer día del resto de la huelga los
sindicatos apelan a parar el país en una
huelga transversal de desde los
transportes hasta la educación o como
decíamos ya los informativos la
refinerías destacamos también la portada
de lemont que titula hoy
bloqueo del país a la vista El Ejecutivo
inquieto dentro del ejecutivo de Manuel
macron algunos ministros perfil bajo
otros dramatizando sobre los posibles
las posibles consecuencias de estas
manifestaciones destacamos también la
portada de la quais que titula Francia
se paraliza ante una jornada que se
prevé de movilizaciones masivas
diferentes sectores han llamado al
bloqueo total del país destacamos la
cuarta portada es la review que titula
pensiones de macron es un no y se
pregunta el movimiento social puede
aguantar Y por último destacamos la boda
que en esta pantalla partida dice semana
decisiva en el senado y en la calle sin
duda una semana decisiva pero vamos a
dejar que se desarrolle la jornada y
haremos después el balance por ahora
cambiamos de tema y comentamos un
artículo del tabloide británico Daily
mail que publicó que uno de los grandes
Aliados del presidente ruso Vladimir
Putin podría haber sido víctima de un
envenenamiento si Ángela nos referimos a
ramsam cadirov el presidente de
chechenia Y probablemente el Aliado más
fiel del presidente ruso Vladimir Putin
en estos momentos Cádiz por ejemplo ha
llamado a la guerra total en Ucrania ha
pedido la ley Marcial e incluso ha
pedido el uso de armas nucleares en
Ucrania este líder checheno podría estar
gravemente enfermo con problemas renales
por un posible envenenamiento según
sostiene el Daily mail además kadir
podría haber recurrido a médicos en
emiratos árabes Unidos por su manifiesta
desconfianza hacia los médicos de Moscú
Fuentes opositoras reflejan a este
tabloide británico que la ausencia de
kadir off en el discurso sobre el estado
de la nación de Putin el mes pasado
podría no estar al calor de esta de este
posible envenenamiento y otros rumores
que caminan en la misma dirección es que
Putin se reunió por primera vez en 20
años con su hijo y no con Cádiz que esto
también podría No pues otro de los
rumores que alientan esta teoría de que
podría estar envenenado recientemente se
ha visto al líder en checheni en la
capital chechena con el líder de la
anexada región de odoniese ucraniana con
la cara visiblemente hinchada como vemos
aquí en la imagen Esta es la foto más
reciente que tenemos de kadir off el
pasado mes de febrero también el propio
cadirov denunció que uno de sus asesores
había sido envenenado a través de un
sobre y denunció intento de asesinato el
Daily mail cita las palabras también de
un periodista kazajo en las que bueno
basadas en sus propias Fuentes decía que
el líder cheno está en estos momentos en
estado crítico como si no tuviéramos ya
suficiente con la guerra Marta Así es en
relación al mismo tema hoy usted nos
trae un análisis de el orden mundial que
evalúa cómo ha evolucionado esta
relación entre chechenia y Rusia de
enemigos a socios de guerra Así es
porque pues no siempre ha habido tanta
sintonía entre No recordemos que los
chechenos son una etnia con su lengua
propia del cáucaso que gobierna Rusia
desde mediados de del siglo XIX con la
caída de la URSS chechenia plantea un
referendo de Independencia Entonces se
independiza Rusia lanza una primera
guerra entre el 94 y el 96 que ganan sin
embargo los separatistas chechenos y
después entre el 99 y el 2000 lanza una
segunda ofensiva está así exitosa y que
catapulta de alguna manera habladimir
Putin agmat kadir off que es el padre
del actual presidente cheno fue un poco
el adalid de esta Victoria rusa no
porque en la Primera Guerra había estado
del lado de Los Insurgentes y en la
Segunda Guerra desertó por eso Putin al
final le termina nombrando presidente y
desde entonces la familia cadirov ha
estado al mando de esta región chechena
ahora pues
actúa como un señor feudal no le muestra
total lealtad a Putin a nivel nacional
pero en su región gobierna el referente
a la guerra por ejemplo los chechenos
que cuentan con 70.000 hombres han
participado de Las batallas más cruentas
como bucha o mariopol pero su ejército
tiene un papel militar o sea más
propagandístico que militar y
rápidamente Marta un tema de la
vanguardia que analiza como Europa se va
fortificado en muros y vallas físicas
con el pretexto de la contención de la
migración irregular o la guerra sí
Ángela Finlandia ha sido el último país
de la Unión Europea en sumarse a esta
tendencia de Barreras físicas con la
construcción de una valla de 200 km en
su frontera con Rusia sin embargo
destaca La Vanguardia que este no es un
mal inherente a la Unión Europea porque
desde la caída del muro de Berlín que
entonces había seis muros en 2022 en
todo el mundo había 74 barreras físicas
en Europa fue España quien abrió la veda
con esa frontera física esa valla para
separar España de Marruecos después con
la ampliación de la Unión Europea en
2004 sumaron otras dos barreras en 2015
La ola migratoria con migrantes de Siria
e Irak bueno siguió fortaleciendo Las
barreras y las fronteras europeas y la
anexión de crimea Rusia también supuso
una una tendencia que continúa en la
actualidad y bueno Más allá de esgrimir
razones migratorias o históricas
sostiene este artículo de la vanguardia
que está fortificación de Europa es la
evolución de la geopolítica global
Muchas gracias a usted Marta y nos vemos
mañana gracias Ángela